ciao a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono papà
oggi siamo su un video un video video
brutto per tutto aggiungo cambi che
brutto prima di cominciare ragazzi come
al solito direi partire con la panarda
settimana che questa settimana è stata
vinta da robert madonna che schifo di
pronuncia di un incarcerare solo per
come l'ho detto la cosa che mi ha fatto
impazzire sono io versione finendo
ragazzi come mai non sta indossando una
delle mie solite magliette della minkia
e perché fuori c'è diluvio universale
quindi se indosso una maglietta rischio
di avere la febbre a 40 in tempo cinque
minuti come sta tornando da tipo 40
minuti la cosa peggiore che mi può
succedere è che a fine blog vi si spenga
il computer perché un fulmine cade
vicino a casa mia cosa che è successa
dieci minuti fa
io questo blog l'ho già registrato ma si
è cancellato tutto caputo ragazzi
passando le news ci sono due newspower
ora non è la conosceva bene sapete già
quella che mi trasferisco nella casa
nuova tipo tra due giorni quindi sarà
una nuova avventura per tutti quanti
perché vi porto con me ovviamente vi
porto a casa mia nel senso che siamo in
due milioni e passa di cristiani in un
appartamento solo se non ci state nel
letto alcuni dormono sul divano svizzero
a cucinare da solo e farò il video di
cucina i casi sono due o mi avveleno o
ordino cinese ma [ __ ] tutte
passiamo alle cose serie perché ci sono
cose epiche che sono successe allora
ragazzi l'altro ieri ho pubblicato una
foto su instagram cliente c'era clapis
che non so perché l'ho visto che
sembrava intento a suicidarsi da il
gradino del marciapiede sembra che
stesse guardando su uno strapiombo non
so che cazzo sta facendo allora mi è
venuta un'idea ho detto o scritto clapis
che tenta suicidio dal regno nel
marciapiede
vi prego qualcuno photoshop in un
precipizio al posto della strada potrei
morire dal ridere cat fork la pista
quando ho fatto sta cosa sono uscite un
puttanaio di foto io ho passato una
mattinata a ridere come un [ __ ]
sull'orlo del precipizio che
l'equilibrio del massimo che cos'è
geniali ragazzi cos'è una banana
cosa c'entra questa ragazza è la
rappresentazione della depressione umana
cioè non c'ha manco il piede sulla trave
bravo bravo va bene
intanto lo scenario di get mario dove si
sta suicidando clapi e poco il cat mario
che mi fa ridere leggermente
sproporzionata questa mi dicono prove
era questo e questa è sproporzionato
scusate ho sbagliato io
bellissimo bravi siete meravigliosi
l'altra roba che mi avete detto che se
si cercano le parole foto d'epoca su
google su immagini esce questa foto qui
chi è che dice che mi somiglia sta tizia
perché nuova ultimamente vi sta
arrivando miliardo di messaggi questa
foto dove la vedete da solo c'è ma beh
forse gli occhi il naso la bocca ma di
certo il caffè ecco forse i capelli in
ordine è una donna
questo sono io in versione donna è
bellissimo non mi singolo farebbe
nessuno prova tempo questo ragazzi sono
concluse le cose importanti appunto
possiamo passare al fuori risponde ma
prima di farlo volevo rispondere alla
domanda che mi avete fatto che l'ho
persa non l'ho più screen nata l'avevo
fatta nello scorso blog quindi vi metto
il pezzo lo scorso blog mi avete chiesto
di fare la reaction a titanic 2 così
ragazzi ho fatto la reaction al trailer
di titanic 2 vi lascio alla reaction ma
io sono carichissimo vedere la roba la
roba cento anni dopo
questo è il titanic cento anni dopo nel
senso che cento anni dopo l'hanno
rifatta giustamente non sono dei geni si
bravo fate la storia allora fair non
lava ma non è un effetto
mica è finta asta scena c'è proprio il
marevero anche il titanic si vede che
proprio vero allora gazineo antiche sono
curioso di vedere ovviamente si suppone
ragazzi che se il primo titani che è
andata a [ __ ] e non ripetono gli
stessi errori che so mica scemi
nello stesso giorno perché dovevano
arrivare lo stesso giorno perfetto
la stessa maledizione quella maledizione
gara dell'iceberg
e lo stesso destino questo è successo
sono venuti tutti ma avete sbattuto
contro mi fate vedere cosa avete colpito
niente sballottato la nave al caso è
calda sembra di vedere un film sulla
guerra in afghanistan
no sulla italia che cazzo è successo
titanic 2 meraviglio mi chiama vedrà di
vederlo sarà meglio del primo che intera
questo è un film porca era peccato che
persona domanda perché volevo volevo
ringraziare quella persona melara
chiesto cesena grazie di avermelo
chiesto mi hai migliorato la giornata
non puoi capire quanto passiamo al fare
risponde normale che è meglio farla la
barba a te non cresce mai come cazzo è
possibile con la barba io sembro un
bambino con una barba finta cioè nel
senso non rende un cazzo non ho gli
ormoni maschili ce ne sono una donna la
figlia io sono una donna beve c'era la
foto prima la capisco quella cosa
cristiana e manca lei mica lasciare la
barca ormai cresciuta più a leica m
carlo nardi come fai adesso che
telecomando si è rotto abbiamo la news
pazzesca ragazzi il buon papi j è
riuscito a riparare il telecomando non
so come ma funziona big like per papi j
che ripara il telecomando è riuscito
perché sono nero nella merda ti ngo prix
italia o su chuck azzida che fai later
entri nel mio video mi dai le views dai
big money una cosa devi fare scrivere un
commento dove mi insulti
cazzo almeno fanno bene dagli games
fascista che fa non so se reputati un
genio per come iscritto a stein fa vi
risponde o per l'avatar di youtube una
delle due perché ci hai una volpe che
mangia un'anguria quando avevi detto che
ti piaceva la musica e di ms così
chiesto artista preferito del settore
dunque mio artista preferito del settore
e martin garris perché a me piace un
sacco ma dall'altro una cosa molto bella
il 25
io non sono mai riuscito a vedere martin
garics in live
e il mio sogno nel cassetto il 25
ottobre c'è martin garics che sta milano
due video trasferire io a dieci minuti
da casa mia quindi 25 ottobre io dove
cazzo dovrebbe a milano a vederlo ed è
la botta di culo più grande della storia
perché finalmente potrò andare a vedere
martin garics non è vero perché devo
essere a bari il 25 ottobre [ __ ]
laida siccome ragazzi il 22 ottobre
uscirà chi adesso mi allaccio astori
scorso il 22 ottobre uscirà che in
therapy come se non lo sapesse nessuno
scalo sa pure la mia go pro che esce che
in terapia comprate go pro illuminati
raccomandati pubblicità occulta gesù in
casa adesso perché in terapia uscirà il
22 ottobre faremo delle date che ho già
messo al post su facebook day date fare
è il 24 il 25 ottobre io sono in puglia
[ __ ] non fraintendiamo io non è
che non vogliono ci mancherebbe anzi
sono contentissimo me piace un sacco a
parte che a me viaggiare piace anche se
vado il molise che non esiste mi diverte
un sacco il problema è che il 25 ottobre
sci e martin garics e io sono in puglia
perché io vado a suicidare come
classiche dobbiamo fare io c'ho st
maledizione io non vedrò mai quel
cristiano pazienza e già che ci sono
ragazzi che ricordo il contest che avevo
già detto due settimane fa prima che
finisca ve lo ripeto per chi volesse
partecipare siccome ed in terapia
partner di cafù con i prodotti allora
marchio potete vincere il film i
biglietti del team in terapia e non solo
anche le magliette ufficiali è una
giornata in mia compagnia perché ci sarà
una giornata che passerò io con i
vincitori di questo contest speriamo non
quando c'è martin garics il live
ma questo è un altro discorso per
partecipare basta andare sul link che vi
lascio nella descrizione e giocare il
codice che c'è che trovate sullo
scontrino quando ve lo danno se trovate
un prodotto che vendono e serve per
sdoppiare le persone magari regalate
melo che io l'altra parte di me la mando
in puglia e io vado a vedere partire in
via da te a fare la spesa a carico era
altissima iniziativa uscì dall'aspetto
la usa vuoi finire finisci piscina
inizialmente
adesso voglio studiavo qui tutto sta
parentesi di popò di roba
quello che vi sia piaciuto ragazzi è la
seconda volta che lo faccio vediamo se
riesce a non cadere un fulmine mentre
sto concludendo perché dovrei di
iniziare tutto da capo e una cosa che
succede ogni tanto e ragazzi raramente
ma succede vorreste vedere la mia
reaction quando perdo tutti i file di
video che stavo registrando è veramente
voglio fare un format solo sulle
incazzature da fulmini con che spero che
video di semplice ragazzi consente se vi
è piaciuto al momento non mi piace non
mi piace per papi gente riaggiusta
telecomando un mi piace se trovate che
la mia versione donna del 1600 sia più
[ __ ] di me cosa che non c'è dubbio è che
la pagina di facebook e come dio stato
nello spezia il sensore t systems e
civile fossimo vito belle ragazze ma che
bello che funziona